[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 16 mars voici le programme de
ce soir quels sont les informations à
retenir dans les Yvelines aujourd'hui
suite au déclenchement de l'article 49-3
pour faire adopter la réforme des
retraites nous avons sollicité les
députés yvelinois mais aussi 85 communes
du département qui entre en situation
d'alerte pour les usages de l'eau
quelles sont les restrictions qui
s'appliquent qu'on fera le point en
début d'émission avec notre journaliste
Céline Charles offrir aux jeunes un
aperçu de la vie d'un sportif de haut
niveau voici l'ambition du programme
génération champion mis en place par
Cisco le partenaire officiel des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 après Roubaix
et Nice et le vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui aura
l'honneur d'accueillir 200 jeunes samedi
prochain pour une après-midi
d'entraînement avec des athlètes
iconiques pour en parler avec nous
Laurent mazory le vice-président délégué
au sport à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
puis comme d'habitude le jeudi à
l'approche du week-end nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines au programme conserve spectacle
et activités sportives ce weekend s'est
également le retour de la soirée disco
roller à Élancourt l'occasion de venir
danser et patiner dans une ambiance
irlandaise pour la Saint Patrick on en
parlera avec Nicolas Thomas le président
du club de roller et en plateau avec moi
Delphine Latry et Hervé Lusson bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous allez tous les deux
participer à la course du coeur c'est
une course qui a pour objectif de
sensibiliser au dons d'organes elles
partira de Paris le 22 mars et fera un
crochet dans les Yvelines Hervé Luçon et
Delphine natri vous êtes les capitaines
de l'équipe entente sportifs Renault
c'est la 20e participation de
l'entreprise Renault pourquoi est-ce que
ça vous tient à cœur de participer à
cette course du cœur
alors il y a deux choses en fait il y a
le il y a le défi sportif on est tous
pratiquants de la course à pied on aime
courir on aime courir en groupe et avant
tout il y a la cause qui est desservie
par
qui est des services par cette course
solidaire qui est de promouvoir le nom
d'organes pour essayer d'avoir un
maximum de ou un minimum de refus
de
greffondre
on peut allier à l'agréable donc en fait
on court c'est ce qu'on fait un peu tout
le temps depuis quelques années et puis
on peut on peut courir pour pour
promouvoir pour parler du don d'organe
autour de soi que ce soit avec avec des
adultes qu'on va rencontrer tout au long
de la course mais aussi avec des enfants
parce que c'est quand même un vecteur
important pour pour parler de ton organe
autour de soi et donc on en parlera un
peu plus en détail tout à l'heure avec
nous également un Laurent mazouri
bonsoir alors vous êtes le
vice-président délégué au sport pour
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je le disais à
l'instant ce samedi le programme
génération champion fait étape au
Vélodrome national au total 200 jeunes
de 8 à 16 ans pour profiter d'une
après-midi à la découverte des sports
olympiques avec des athlètes
professionnels
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et terre de
jeux 2024 c'est une fierté je suppose
pour l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
d'être partenaire de ce programme
génération champion bien sûr c'est une
fierté bien sûr d'être terre d'accueil
des Jeux Olympiques et donc dans ce
cadre là le fait de participer
activement à cette opération génération
champion puis le départ Cisco partenaire
premium des Jeux Olympiques s'imposaient
pour nous parce que c'est également
avant tout une manière d'apporter le
sport au plus grand nombre puisque les
Jeux Olympiques ont cette particularité
d'être du sport de haut niveau et malgré
les capacités d'accueil de nos
installations et seront forcément
limitées toute la population
malheureusement nos 220 000 habitants ne
pourront pas y assister et donc
permettre cette ouverture et cette
pratique du sport de haut niveau dans un
lieu magique comme le vélodrome
s'imposait bien entendu à nous donc on
en parlera également un peu plus en
détail dans quelques instants et enfin
avec nous une journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 c'est l'une Charles
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous vous allez
nous présenter vos idées de sortie pour
ce week-end dans les Yvelines de quoi
est-ce que vous allez nous parler Céline
je vais vous parler de musique de sport
et un petit peu de poésie et donc ce
sera enfin d'émission restez bien avec
nous dans quelques instants également le
point sur les informations du jour à
retenir dans les Yvelines mais avant
jetons un coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera nuageux avec
des averses à prévoir du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan au niveau de
Versailles et Rambouillet ça devrait
rester sec selon Météo France côté
température il fera 10 degrés vers ou
dans Versailles et Rambouillet et il
fera 11 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie dans
l'après-midi le ciel sera toujours bien
chargé à Versailles et Rambouillet la
pluie sera toujours présente vers
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan côté
température il fera 15 degrés en moyenne
sur l'ensemble des Yvelines et demain
nous fêterons la Saint-Patrick nous
souhaiterons donc une bonne fête à notre
journaliste Patrick Jacques de dispute
et maintenant le point sur les
informations du jour dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Céline Charle on
commence par ces informations du jour
par la réforme des retraites c'était
mouvementée cet après-midi à l'Assemblée
nationale oui Mathilde est d'ailleurs je
vous promets je vous propose de
commencer avec cette séquence parce que
je suis attaché à notre modèle social et
parce que je crois dans la dém
ocratie c'est sur votre réforme sur le
texte du Parlement fruit d'un compromis
entre les deux assemblées que je suis
prête à engager ma responsabilité
c'est sous une Marseillaise les huée
d'une partie de l'Assemblée nationale
que la première ministre Elisabeth borne
s'est exprimée cet après-midi devant les
députés elle a déclenché l'article 49-3
de la Constitution pour faire adopter le
projet de loi de réformes des retraites
sans vote à la mi-journée manuel Macron
avait convoqué un conseil des ministres
en urgence pour autoriser ce recours on
écoute tout de suite la député
renaissance des Yvelines Marie le bec
en majorité relative pour le pack autour
du président de la de la République et
pendant plusieurs jours plusieurs
semaines on a cherché à négocier à
élargir cette majorité pour obtenir un
accord sur ce texte des groupes
politiques comme les républicains qui
pourtant c'était engagé à l'occasion de
leur campagne à une retraite à 65 ans
avec soi-disant des mesures beaucoup
plus ambitieuses non pas souhaité
soutenir le texte et donc nous n'étions
pas en capacité d'assurer que le texte
passerait or ce texte est fondamental
c'est un en du président de la de la
République et donc il est apparu
nécessaire au président et à la première
ministre puis à la majorité de passer ce
texte en 49-3 les groupes d'opposition
ont déjà annoncé le dépôt de plusieurs
notions de censure écouter William
Martinet député nue pèse de la 11e
circonscription je crois que c'est
d'abord une trahison démocratique qui va
rendre encore plus illégitime ce projet
de loi qu'il était déjà beaucoup parce
qu'il est rejeté par l'écrasante
majorité des français par la totalité
des organisations syndicales et donc le
gouvernement continue dans sa stratégie
qui est de faire un passage en force
émotion de censure évidemment parce que
c'est constitutionnellement la riposte
aux 49-3 et j'espère que elle sera votée
le plus largement possible et je pense
notamment du côté des républicains
de son côté le groupe les républicains
d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il ne voterait
pas en faveur d'émotions de censure
l'Inter syndicale elle doit se réunir ce
jeudi soir pour décider de la suite du
mouvement de grève hier la commission
mixte paritaire était parvenue à un
accord pour un texte commun entre
députés et sénateurs le texte a
d'ailleurs été adopté ce matin par les
sénateurs une autre information
importante maintenant Céline le
département des Yvelines est entré en
situation d'alerte pour les usages de
l'eau c'est le centre du département qui
est plus exactement concerné par l'arrêt
préfectoral la raison la situation
exceptionnelle de sécheresse en période
hivernale les faibles précipitations à
entraîné une absence de recherche
suffisante des nappes 85 communes sont
concernées cette situation d'alerte
entraîne par exemple l'interdiction
d'arrosage des pelouses et jardins
potagers entre 11 heures et 18h ou
encore celle de l'alimentation des
fontaines publiques ou privées en
circuit ouvert les autres zones saines
sud-ouest et sud-est sont en vigilance
en situation de vigilance et alors une
autre information Céline c'est Emitech
qui lance tout nouveau centre d'essai
véhicules effectivement le groupe
installé à Montigny-le-Bretonneux
investi 10 millions d'euros dans ce
nouvel outil dont l'équipement principal
est la plus grande cage de Faraday de
France elle est dédiée aux essais de
véhicules et aux tests de grossistes et
consiste à vérifier la capacité d'un
matériel électrique ou électronique à
fonctionner de façon satisfaisante sans
provoquer de perturbations et il se
lançait le défi en septembre dernier
collecté des fonds pour financer
l'opération de trois enfants malades
hier soir mercredi 15 mars les maires de
Villepreux et Le Port-Marly révélé le
montant obtenu par l'association élue du
coeur écoutez c'est surprenant on
s'attendait vraiment à remplir
l'objectif des 24000 euros on s'en
donnait les moyens mais là les 36000
euros c'était une vraie belle surprise
et fort de cette expérience et de la
réussite du succès de de l'opération et
encore une fois en raison aussi de
l'extraordinaire solidarité et
générosité des personnes qui sont là ce
soir on a décidé et bien de poursuivre
l'aventure déjà en étoffant et j'espère
qu'on aura de nouvelles adhésions ce
soir mais on est au fond les rangs des
élus du cœur puisque on le rappelle
cette association est ouverte aux élus
mais pas uniquement et puis en proposant
ce sera d'ailleurs un des objectifs de
la soirée un certain nombre de défis
sportifs il y en aura pour tous les
goûts pour tous les niveaux et les deux
mers ont d'ailleurs le regard déjà
tourné va être vers un autre rendez-vous
tout à fait Mathilde half marathon en
Jordanie à la fin de l'année 2023 on
poursuit ses informations du jour par un
nouveau job dating c'est oui on vous en
annoncé deux hier maintenant c'est le
magasin Leclerc de Bois-d'Arcy qui
organise le sien il se déroulera il se
déroulera le 25 mars prochain au sein
même de l'enseigne plus de 50 postes
seront proposés poissonniers boulanger
ou encore pâtissier vous avez la
possibilité de déposer votre candidature
sur le site recrutement point Leclerc
avant de vous rendre directement en
magasin mais aussi de vous présenter
spontanément sur place merci beaucoup
c'est ninja et puis vous aussi comme
d'habitude si vous voyez une information
ou une image qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news
samedi prochain les jeunes ont
rendez-vous avec le sport au Vélodrome
national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les coachs et
athlètes professionnels de la team Cisco
partenaire officiel des Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 accueilleront 200 jeunes
de 8 à 16 ans baptisé génération
champion le but est de faire découvrir
les sports olympiques et paralympique
pour en parler avec nous Laurent mazory
le vice-président délégué au sport pour
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors quels
sont les objectifs de ce programme le
ramazori est-ce que c'est de transmettre
les valeurs du sport alors c'est de
transmettre et valeurs du sport mais
c'est aussi de le faire découvrir parce
qu'on a un certain nombre de jeunes qui
n'ont de vision du sport que ce qu'ils
ont mieux scolaire voir avec nos amis de
l'UNSS qui travaillent essentiellement
le mercredi et pour autant on est
souvent éloigné de ce que sont de ce
qu'est la pratique du sport au quotidien
mais également la pratique du sport de
haut niveau on a l'impression que
c'était un petit peu loin que ce sont
des gens hors normes que les sportifs
c'est pas nous et on était on veut que
les que les enfants de Saint-Quentin
comme de l'ensemble des Yvelines
puissent se rendre compte qu'en réalité
c'est à leur portée qu'en pratiquant un
sport en amateur on peut progresser on
peut y prendre beaucoup de plaisir on
peut évidemment sauvegarder sa santé
mais on peut aussi travailler sur des
valeurs qui vont au-delà de celle du
sport et que le sport porte les valeurs
de respect les valeurs de de
d'appréhension et de compréhension des
règles les valeurs de travail en commun
pour les sports collectifs les valeurs
également de savoir appliquer respecter
des horaires les valeurs de se respecter
déjà soi-même ça sont des valeurs que
porte le sport et que porte le sport de
haut niveau en terme d'exemplarité mais
en termes de pratique également au
quotidien et peut-être révéler de futurs
grands talents ah bah écoutez je
l'espère 50 individus on a déjà produit
beaucoup dans beaucoup de disciplines je
me porte au golf je pense à la boxe je
pense à nos para raclette puisque les
parallèles sur Saint-Quentin sont très
présents et le sont fortement à la fois
dans la pratique de leur sport mais
d'ailleurs également sur le travail de
l'innovation qui découle de la pratique
du de tout ce qui est le parathlétisme
mais pas que je pense au tir à l'arc
vous savez nous aurons du tir à l'arc
nous aurons du BMX nous aurons un
ensemble d'éléments qui sont à la fois
du sport et qui relèvent de haute
technologie dans la pratique des usages
et du matériel qu'on utilise pour
pouvoir progresser dans ses sports
seront sur le territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines durant les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 on revient un peu sur
Génération champion quel sera le
programme de l'après-midi globalement
avec ces 200 jeunes quels sont les
sports qui vont pouvoir découvrir alors
le programme je note je regarde mes
notes parce qu'en fait il est tellement
touffu donc on a environ 4h d'activités
diverses et variées d'ailleurs essayez
encore de vous inscrire et peut-être
quelques places sur le site vous pouvez
aller sur le site de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines ce qui
challenge.fr skit challengec.fr
merci on est dans une synchronisation
parfaite donc on a quatre heures de
pratique de ces différents sports on a
des grands athlètes qui sont présents je
pense à Vincent Luis qui est athlète et
qui a été médaillé aux Jeux Olympiques
de Tokyo récemment Ladji Doucouré qu'on
ne présente plus hein qui est champion
du monde du 110 mètres exact donc eux
ils vont être là sur tout ce qui touche
à l'emblème à porter ses jeunes et puis
les épreuves c'est donc le BMX le tir à
l'arc le basket l'athlétisme et le
tennis je tiens beaucoup au tennis
fauteuil parce que d'abord c'est très
dur et c'est un sport qui est très
spectaculaire et on ne faut pas avoir
d'a priori j'insiste beaucoup sur le
parathlétisme parce que vous savez qu'on
accueillera aussi des épreuves sur notre
territoire pour les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de 2024 il faut que les
jeunes le voir il faut pouvoir s'y
impliquer et on peut pratiquer ce para
fauteuil quand on est pas soi-même
atteint de handicap donc il faut le
savoir et là on se rend compte de
l'effort que ça représente et tout cela
sera bien entendu encadré par les
équipes de professionnels qui sont là
pour accueillir à la fois les jeunes
mais aussi leur famille bien sûr le
vélodrome est très grand et il
accueillir à tout le monde sans aucune
difficulté alors comment ça va se passer
ils vont se challenger dans des ateliers
oui oui alors on est sur le même modèle
que ce que l'on fait j'allais dire
quotidiennement en Vélodrome quand on
pratique le cyclisme il y a une phase de
compréhension et d'appréhension de
chacun de ces sports on apprend les
règles et pratiques quand on ne les
connaît pas ou on arrive à maîtriser les
différents outils quand il y en a besoin
je pense au tir à l'arc par exemple et
puis petit à au fil de la journée on va
commencer en individuel et en collectif
puis après il y aura des petites
compétitions
d'un très très bon niveau qui
permettront aux autres de s'affronter
dans un esprit sportif et alors on est à
moins maintenant de 500 jours des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 est-ce qu'il y
a d'autres échéances comme ça à venir
comme génération champion qui vont
arriver à 50 ans en Yvelines alors on a
la semaine olympique qui est un petit
peu notre point récurrent qui a lieu
début avril dans dans 15 jours
maintenant enfin trois semaines entre 15
jours et trois semaines c'est un
événement important parce que entre
autres sur 50 ans Yvelines nous
dévoilerons un certain nombre de choses
qui touchent à la communication et au
sentiment d'appartenance donc je ne
pourrai pas le faire ce soir parce que
il y a ce qu'on appelle en anglais The
Revel donc le moment on va révéler tout
cela et ça c'est le point très récurrent
on a la nationale golf 8 également qui
arrive pareil dans 5 semaines maintenant
et qui est un élément maintenant 58 mois
qui est récurrent où tous les passionnés
de golf se retrouvent amateurs comme
professionnel avec une importante
commission de golf qui sera greffée
également là bien sûr on a récurrente
d'entrepreneurs de France qui auront
lieu cette année au mois de septembre on
est très heureux de l'accueillir à
nouveau avec là aussi je pense à nouveau
sponsor mais je laisse la Fédération
française nous en parler et puis vous
savez ce qui est plus important que tout
et que peut-être la population voit le
plus sont les travaux je pense entre
autres aux travaux de la commune
d'Élancourt parce qu'il faut également
qu'on ait des lieux pour accueillir nos
champions et la population on a cette
chance à Saint-Quentin d'avoir un golf
qui est déjà prêt à qui est déjà prêt et
un stade de BMX qui lui aussi est prêt
par contre on a des travaux sur la
colline d'Élancourt pour accueillir les
épreuves de VTT et ça c'est très visible
pour toute notre population en tout cas
le sport vit bien dans les Yvelines se
porte bien en tout cas au milieu que
nulle part dans les Yvelines je parlais
du golf vous savez peut-être ou si vous
ne savez pas je vous la prends le
territoire de golf le plus fort de
France ce sont les Yvelines puisque
c'est la divine que nous avons le plus
de terrain de golf on en a pas 78 mais
on est pas loin et bien merci beaucoup
Laurent mazory pour toutes ces
précisions nous suivrons de près cet
après-midi au Vélodrome national je
rappelle les quelques informations
pratiques génération champion c'est ce
samedi 18 mars au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de 13h à 18h30
l'inscription est obligatoire sur le
site internet qui va s'afficher sur
votre écran
venez nombreux on continue de parler
sport avec un portrait à présent meryl
locquette et ta tête de haut niveau en
PARAD badminton grâce à son sport et
visite chaque année plusieurs pays son
handicap n'est pas un frein à sa soif de
découverte au contraire Céline Charles
est allé à sa rencontre regarder
meryloquette est athlète de haut niveau
de parabadminton quatrième mondial de la
catégorie joueur debout avec un handicap
d'un membre supérieur il vise maintenant
la qualification aux Jeux paralympiques
de Paris 2024 avec plus d'une dizaine de
pays parcourus à l'année avec la
Fédération Française de Badminton ou en
famille les quatre coins du globe n'ont
plus de secret pour lui c'était cet
hiver en décembre ça se voit il fait
froid c'était à la Réunion et j'ai fait
le Piton des Neiges pour voir déjà un
jour faire les jeux c'est un truc de
dingue et en plus de faire le tour du
monde de décorer
en fait le monde quoi les gens la
culture c'est un truc de fou c'est
souvent des phrases bateaux ouais
j'adore pour la culture
sur plein de trucs c'est une ouverture
d'esprit que je kiffe vraiment c'est
trop bien
atteint d'une agénésie au bras droit
mais il n'en fait pas une contrainte
lors de ses voyages au contraire à Bali
il y a beaucoup de petites mobylettes et
c'est les choses de truc que je peux pas
faire en fait j'ai pris un genre
d'élastique comme ça là que j'ai mis
autour de l'accélérateur j'ai mis ma
main dedans et en fait avec la pression
d'élastique ça a serré l'accélérateur et
dès que je faisais ça ça accéléré du
coup c'est de la débrouille mais j'ai
trop kiffé même si certains obstacles
s'imposent de même pour lui ou son
équipe
on était en Ouganda en Afrique et
pas d'ascenseur pas de rampe donc à
chaque petite étape je devais être là
pour soit soulever le fauteuil soit le
lever
prendre le fauteuil le remettre sur le
fauteuil parce que en fait tout était
une épreuve et là je me suis rendu
compte que waouh c'est chiant quoi c'est
hyper galère
au niveau de la vision des gens et de
leur mentalité elle est très différente
dans les pays par contre asiatiques
les pays arabes et tout donc c'est le
regard de l'handicap n'est pas le même
je pourrais pas te dire si c'est positif
ou négatif mais en tout cas il y a un
regard qui est qui pèse un peu malgré
les difficultés mériles portent un
regard optimiste sur le handicap et son
accessibilité je peux tout faire
je trouve que il y a plus trop de
limites à avoir dans tous les domaines
qui soient quand on a un handicap je
trouve quand même le monde il évolue
dans la mentalité dans l'adaptation de
tout il y a un peu de retard dans
certains pays dans certains continents
mais en général si on s'y prend un peu à
l'avance si on réfléchit un petit peu il
y a pas de souci dans sa course pour les
Jeux Olympiques de Paris 2024 mais il
doit affronter une dizaine de tournois
partout dans le monde sa prochaine
destination le Brésil dans deux semaines
il s'agit de la 36e édition La Course du
Coeur est un événement sportif et
solidaire qui vise à sensibiliser au
dons d'organes organisé par
l'association transforme elle met
également en avant les exploits des
coureurs qui ont subi une greffe ou une
transplantation elle partira de Paris le
22 mars et sera deux passages dans 4
communes Yvelines pour en parler avec
nous deux participants Delphine Latry et
Hervé Luçon alors vous êtes les
capitaines de l'équipe Entente Sportive
Renault on en parlait un petit peu en
début d'émission il s'agit de la 20e
participation de codé coureurs Renault
pourquoi cette cause tient autant à
coeur à l'entreprise alors cette cause
tient autant à coeur à l'entreprise déjà
au travers l'engagement des
collaborateurs de l'entreprise première
participation en 1993 donc 30 ans sur
la volonté d'un collaborateur
qui concernait par cette cause donc a
mis en place et qui a connu donc cette
association transforme a décidé de
mettre en place en fait ce challenge au
sein donc de l'entreprise et ben
l'entreprise les collaborateurs on s'est
on s'est pris on s'est pris au jeu et du
coup
chaque année qui passe on arrive
toujours à repartir avec une équipe avec
des collaborateurs qui sont motivés pour
la cause et aussi pour le Défi sportif
et tout ce que l'on vit au travers les
quatre jours quatre nuits donc là vous
êtes 14 au total dans votre équipe et
c'est dans ce cadre de cette course du
coeur que vous avez organisé plusieurs
actions de sensibilisation auprès des
écoles et d'autres et d'autres actions
également oui tout à fait ça fait
quelques mois déjà qu'on
a qu'on a lancé la communication autour
de l'événement dans les écoles donc dans
les villes on est passé par des écoles
dans les centres de loisirs plutôt de
Guyancourt par exemple les écoles de
voisins Bretonneux aussi
on a ces actions là on a des actions
aussi plus orientées internes donc chez
Renault dans l'entreprise avec une
conférence qui a eu lieu mi-avril
mi-février pardon on a fait intervenir
un collaborateur greffé et également un
chirurgien transplant transplanteur
quoi d'autre alors on va plus loin que
le département 78 c'est-à-dire on a ce
type d'action aussi dans des
départements dans l'Eure je suis
j'habite dans l'Eure on a aussi des
actions dans l'Est on a des actions sur
Lyon donc on essaye parce qu'on a des
collaborateurs un petit peu partout et
du coup on essaie d'avoir cette cette
démarche pour rentrer dans dans les
écoles aller voir aller au contact des
enfants pour essayer des sensibiliser on
sait très bien que les enfants sont un
vecteur d'information ils en parlent
après avec leurs parents et du coup on
traversa on arrive à déclencher le
dialogue autour de la cause du don
d'organes et on va donc c'est
véritablement un axe important qu'on a
voulu mettre en place qu'on perpétue
d'année en année mais parce que il faut
sortir donc faut sortir de l'entreprise
donc on essaie d'aller au plus près de
l'ensemble des collaborateurs du Groupe
Renault mais on essaye aussi de sortir
de l'entreprise selon vous les Français
ne sont pas suffisamment sensibilisés
aux dons d'organes
oui oui il y a un chiffre qui le montre
tout à fait parce que même si depuis le
changement de la loi en 2017 où tout le
monde est d'honneur automatique il y a à
peu près 40 pardon
il y a aujourd'hui les chiffres remontés
par l'Agence de biomédecine c'est à peu
près 40% ou 33% de refus de de donner le
don d'organes donc c'est pour ça que
c'est c'est on en parle pas assez ça
fait beaucoup d'années que l'association
transforme est sur le enfin sur sur le
sujet
mais ça montre ses 40% montre que dans
les chaumières de France
le message il passe pas encore donc faut
continuer et ce type d'action ce type de
course solidaire et là pour pour faire
passer le message le plus important
savoir c'est que effectivement par
défaut on est d'honneur si on le refuse
pas en revanche lorsqu'un événement tel
quel apparaît
c'est à la famille qu'on demande et si
on en a pas parlé autour de soi à sa
famille à ses proches à ses amis
auparavant et bien on peut on risque de
de passer à côté de ça est-ce qu'il y a
une limite d'âge pour pouvoir faire un
don se faire un quels sont les
conditions pour pouvoir faire un don
d'organes
il y a un âge mini il me semble alors
il me semble qu'il y a un âge mini et
pour moi il y a pas d'âge maxi voilà on
peut donner de et on peut aussi alors ça
c'est des choses qui sont méconnus mais
on peut donner de son vivant il y a des
organes que l'on peut donner on a eu
l'exemple très récemment d'un
collaborateur qui est greffé qui greffé
aura son fils touché par la même maladie
a eu un greffon d'un de ses collègues
donc c'est un don du vivant donc voilà
donc il y a les greffes donc par mort
enfin les créons qui viennent donc d'une
mort et puis il y a les greffons du
vivant donc il y a le foie il y a le
donc les reins
qui peuvent être donnés de son vivant et
du coup du
cette 37 km cette année ça va arriver
cette année on a eu les chiffres il y a
pas longtemps 837 et ça va vous être
près du coup vous allez vous relayer
l'équipe est prête l'équipe se prépare
la façon la plus sérieuse possible on
recherche pas la performance sportive
c'est pas forcément c'est pas l'objet de
ces courses du cœur parce que c'est
vraiment le message du don qui est au
centre de tout mais on a besoin comme on
est quatre jours quatre nuits il faut
être en mesure d'encaisser la fatigue et
du coup on s'entraîne comme si on
préparait un marathon donc l'ensemble de
l'équipe à un niveau enfin performe
comme s'ils allaient faire le marathon
et d'ailleurs certains de l'équipe
postent cause du coeur vont faire le
marathon de Paris
et bien merci beaucoup de
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je vous
souhaite bonne chance pour cette course
du coeur et j'espère que ça va bien se
passer pour vous deux merci c'est le
dernier épisode de notre série avec
Fabien Lambert le premier Eco garde
professionnel des Yvelines recrutées en
octobre dernier par la mairie de Beynes
son but et de veiller aux espaces verts
de la commune nous l'avons suivi lors de
ces différentes missions le temps d'une
journée ce soir pour ce dernier épisode
faire bien l'envers se charge du
nettoyage de la rivière de la mode
regardée
[Musique]
je remets un petit peu spécial on va
procéder au nettoyage de la rivière
Mauldre qui passe derrière la mairie de
Beynes donc c'est un nettoyage annuel
effectué par l'association de pêche et
donc cette année on a décidé enfin j'ai
décidé de me joindre à l'association de
pêche pour leur apporter de l'aide et
puis des connaissances il y a aussi
quelques collègues ecoga qui vont se
joindre à nous pour nous prêter main
forte et pour pouvoir travailler plus
efficacement
[Musique]
on va nettoyer la rivière sur un petit
peu plus de 2 km c'est la distance du
parcours de pêche mais il faut savoir
que la rivière est beaucoup plus longue
que 2 km donc on va pas pouvoir tout
nettoyer aujourd'hui évidemment les
tubes des déchets qu'on va retrouver
dans la mode ça va être principalement
des déchets végétaux des branchages du
bois mais aussi de la boue qui va
obstruer l'écoulement de la rivière et
on retrouve aussi beaucoup de déchets de
qui proviennent de l'homme des canettes
des sachets en plastique et puis des
gravats etc donc c'est
dangereux pour la faune la flore et puis
ça pollue l'environnement donc on va
essayer de faire la sensibilisation pour
limiter ce phénomène
[Musique]
donc voilà vous avez vu aujourd'hui la
journée un petit peu type d'un éco garde
il y a aussi beaucoup d'autres missions
comme la sensibilisation des riverains
le ramassage des déchets l'évacuation
des dépôts avec les services techniques
de la mairie bien évidemment qui me
prêtent ma force et puis tout ce qui est
aussi réunion et puis projet
administratif organisation de la Fête de
la Nature c'est vraiment tout ce qui
après à l'environnement moi j'aime bien
résumer le poste comme principalement de
la patrouille sur le chemin communaux
mais aussi de la coordination de tous
les acteurs environnementaux de la
commune si vous aussi vous voulez
devenir ecoga c'est possible en tant que
professionnel aujourd'hui je suis le
seul sur le département des Yvelines
mais vous pouvez toujours devenir
bénévole grâce aux dispositifs ecogar
donc merci et à bientôt
[Musique]
et si vous avez manqué certains épisodes
vous pourrez retrouver l'intégralité de
ce long formation notre chaîne YouTube
allez c'est l'heure maintenant d'ouvrir
une page de loisirs
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisirs par un
concert le silence de la forêt un
concert pas comme les autres de virtuose
Olivia gay et Célia Oneto Bensa Bensaid
Ben Saïd on choisit de poser leur
instrument au cœur de la forêt de
Rambouillet pour en parler avec nous
Philippe Nizou bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes le président et le fondateur
de l'association lipsart et Didier
Auffret bonsoir vous êtes le
co-fondateur et vous êtes en charge de
la création pour l'association lipsart
alors en amont à votre de parler de ce
concert est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter cette association avec plaisir
où nous avons fondé avec Stéphane 1 qui
n'a pas pu venir ce soir cette
association il y a un petit peu plus
d'un an en fait on a tout fait pour pas
la monter mais je suis élu à la mairie
des Bréviaires et c'était difficile avec
la comptabilité
du village de continuer à être
totalement transparent donc face aux
difficultés on a décidé avec le maire du
village la création de cette association
donc je suis devenu le président malgré
moi
et avec un grand plaisir et j'ai d'abord
demandé aux artistes notamment à
Philippe herouet et à Rachel place à
l'harmonica Philippe pirouette qui le
guitariste de Saint-Germain Enrico
Macias si j'avais leur caution s'ils
étaient prêts à me suivre et ensuite
j'ai appelé deux amis Didier Auffret et
Stéphane 1 pour leur dire est-ce que
vous êtes prêt à me suivre parce qu'on
va pas faire des projets pour s'occuper
parce que nous ne sommes pas nous à la
retraite parce que c'est le thème du
moment mais bien pour faire des projets
qui n'ont jamais eu lieu ici dans les
Yvelines mais alors quel est l'objectif
de
cette
d'amener comme la très bien dit Philippe
Cohen des nouvelles d'amener la culture
à nous parce qu'il y a il se passe plein
de choses mais ce qu'on voulait c'était
faire des choses un petit peu original
et se faire plaisir parce que la culture
c'est d'abord pour se faire plaisir
parce que sinon c'est un petit peu
ennuyeux et j'ai contacté Claude Lemelle
le président de la SACEM parce que notre
première idée a été de monter un récital
sur la chanson française et Claude
Lemelle a accepté d'être le parrain donc
nous allons d'ailleurs le samedi 25 mars
fêter la troisième édition de la chanson
française à la portée de tous aux
bréviaires et alors ce samedi 13 mai
vous organisez un concert en pleine
forêt de Rambouillet pourquoi organiser
un concert en pleine forêt de
Rambouillet
en pleine nature
[Musique]
c'est une immense coïncidence et c'est
des jours où tout s'aligne et j'ai
écouté France Info et je suis tombé sur
Olivia gay et qui nous expliquait son
amour à la forêt et ce qu'elle avait
décidé de faire et donc j'ai contacté la
seule personne de la commission
culturelle des brevières qui est agent
d'artiste classique et elle m'a répondu
oui c'est une amie je la connais donc en
deux heures je suis rentré en contact
avec elle on s'est rencontré et je lui
ai fait découvrir les brevières et une
idée qu'on avait eu qui était la table
du roi et donc on a établi un cahier des
charges ça s'appelle comme ça quand on
commence par monter un projet c'est à
dire est-ce qu'on est capable de réunir
le budget et on a réussi à boucler le
budget en une semaine et Olivia viendra
accompagner de Célia en forêt de
Rambouillet mais le concept a d'abord
été validé par l'Office National des
Forêts c'est à dire que qu'Olivia Vienne
avec son violoncelle c'est une
performance mais par contre le piano et
ça remorque
amener un piano en pleine forêt alors
d'abord elle s'occupait de tout
faire au niveau technique mais en fait
le piano vient de Bourges sur une
remorque qui a été validée qui est
spécifique mais c'est surtout la
l'aspect original c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y
aura pas d'amplificateur il n'y aura pas
de son autre que le bruit des feuilles
et le son des instruments donc en fait
ce projet avait d'abord été validé par
l'ONF et j'avais déjà eu le plaisir de
venir vous rencontrer il y a quelques
années puisque j'avais créé une fondée
une une association environnementale
c'était totalement moi ce que je voulais
faire c'était la créer un pont entre la
musique et l'art j'en ai encore parlé ce
matin avec elle et la nature donc
l'acoustique sera forcément différente
en pleine nature
non mais l'idée c'est aussi de lancer
promouvoir
innover aussi avec les artistes donc
c'est là où c'est pour nous quelque
chose d'important pour retrouver un peu
notre espace et notre temps avec les
artistes parce que ce sont des gens qui
sont le plus souvent et surtout en ce
moment oubliés et il est important aussi
au niveau local d'avoir cette relation
nouvelle et cette pérennité aussi avec
eux donc c'est pour ça que existe aussi
c'est pour permettre de retrouver ce
lien dont on a besoin parce que les
artistes sont quand même des gens qui
nous donnent une sensibilité et qui nous
permettent d'échanger entre nous une
partie importante des bénéfices sera
reversée au fond ONF font agir pour la
forêt absolument voilà donc là je prends
ma casquette de financier
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait on a pas encore
débuté les réservations on attendait de
vous rencontrer d'avoir en avait on
avait donné notre parole aussi parce que
vous nous aviez déjà reçu on attend
l'article
bonne nouvelle également et pour que la
presse régionale soit priorisée parce
que c'est déjà un événement un concept
qui a un écho certains sur la presse
nationale et moi je suis là pour
défendre l'ipsart lorsqu'on a inventé ce
nom c'est lancé innover promouvoir et
soutenir les arts et les artistes du 78
donc on n'est pas là par hasard et donc
tout le monde a adhéré et on est pour
l'instant tous se passe bien et on va
ouvrir les réservations officiellement
au mélomane parce qu'on a beaucoup de
demandes ça commence un petit peu de
savoir on a fait une affiche qui a été
qui a été la photographie a été faite
dans la forêt de Rambouillet donc on va
mettre en avant notre département et je
vais mettre en avant mon village des
brevières puisque c'est le silence de la
forêt de Rambouillet sur la commune des
Brévières puisque dans les partenaires
que j'ai je me permets de les saluer
parce qu'on a eu des déceptions
lorsqu'on envoyait des dossiers sur
d'autres projets on a notamment eu
aucune réponse sur un projet qui pour
moi était fantastique qui s'appelait ça
te dénight lumière parce qu'on va parler
tout à l'heure à DJ et tout le monde me
suivait les agriculteurs nous avaient
mis l'échange j'avais 100 tonnes de
paille en fin on a fait un gros projet
qui n'a absolument pas été suivi on a
même eu aucune réponse donc nous avons
décidé de nous prendre en main et de
faire ça avec des financements privés et
aujourd'hui le CIC deux Rambouillet nous
a suivis parce que je les ai convaincus
que le CIC c'était la musique classique
notamment la scène musicale avec
Philippe Jaroussky son Academy que je
connais bien et Phoenix development un
petit peu la Financière d'archipel mais
j'en parle pas trop parce que comme
c'est ma structure je n'ai pas le droit
mais on a décidé de commencer par le
commencement si on veut exister il faut
qu'on ait les moyens mais les moyens
humains on les avait les moyens
financiers c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué et après on avait besoin de
vous la presse locale pour vous qui
croyez dans la culture il faut qu'on ait
les moyens de se développer et on peut
pas le faire n'importe comment il faut
le structurer ça manque un peu de poésie
mais si on n'a pas ça au départ on ne
pourra rien faire et bien merci Philippe
Nizou et Didier au frais d'avoir répondu
à nos questions le récital le silence de
la forêt aura lieu le samedi 13 mai en
forêt de Rambouillet sur le site de la
table du roi au bréviaire le tarif et de
50 euros un tiers du billet sera reversé
au fond agir pour la forêt si vous êtes
intéressé vous pouvez réserver votre
place sur le site internet qui s'affiche
juste en dessous c'est le début d'une
nouvelle série sur notre chaîne Mélissa
sebir et styliste et modiste à
Richebourg dans les Yvelines elle a
fondé sa propre marque la mode de
Mélissa elle va vous partager ses
meilleurs conseils sur TV 78 pour savoir
comment bien vous habiller au quotidien
pour ce premier épisode elle vous donne
quelques astuces pour allonger votre
silhouette que vous soyez grande ou
petite
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Mélissa sebir et je
suis la fondatrice de la mode de Mélissa
aujourd'hui je suis là avec vous pour
vous partager des conseils mode et on va
commencer par quelques techniques pour
rallonger votre silhouette
[Musique]
alors que vous soyez grande ou petite le
but c'est vraiment de vous donner des
conseils très très simples à mettre en
place et très simple à faire avec ce que
vous avez dans votre garde-robe pour que
vous ayez justement une silhouette qui
est beaucoup plus grande si vous voulez
prochainement acheter des pantalons il
faut savoir qu'il ne faut pas prendre
n'importe quoi si vous voulez allonger
votre silhouette je vous déconseille
fortement de prendre des pantalons
taille basse c'est pas très beau déjà ça
ne met pas en avant votre silhouette et
ça va venir casser la hauteur en fait de
de perception qu'on a de votre
silhouette et du coup vous allez faire
plus petit que prévu d'ailleurs que vous
soyez grand ou pas cette solution là
vous vous tassera en fait clairement ces
mots que je cherchais
donc l'idée c'est de prendre des
pantalons taille haute le plus haut
possible de façon à ce que ça arrive au
dessus de votre nombril parce que c'est
vraiment le centre en fait de votre de
votre silhouette et c'est lui qui est
extrêmement important pour vous galber
pour paraître plus grande plus mince etc
donc je vais vous montrer
l'idée c'est de prendre des pantalons
taille haute et de les positionner comme
je vous disais au dessus du nombril et
en fait naturellement votre taille va
être destinée et vous allez avoir
l'impression d'avoir des gens très très
grandes et voilà comment paraître plus
grande que prévu et la preuve en est on
pense toujours que je suis quelqu'un de
très très grande quand on regarde mes
vidéos alors que je ne fais que 1m56
voilà autre astuce aussi hyper simple à
rectifier très rapidement les trois
quarts du temps les jeans ou les
pantalons de manière générale ont un
certain standard et souvent les jambes
sont beaucoup trop grandes du coup ça
vous fait des espèces de plis ou de
gouttière vous voyez sur le bas du
pantalon et l'idée c'est de venir faire
un ourlet pour finalement couper le
vêtement le pantalon à votre taille il
n'y aura plus cet effet vous savez de
gouttière comme ça sur le bas du
pantalon vous aurez un effet droit comme
ici et en fait c'est ça qui va venir
aussi allonger votre silhouette
[Musique]
et voilà je vous ai donc donné quelques
petits conseils pour allonger votre
silhouette que vous soyez grande ou
petit et n'oubliez pas le but c'est que
vous vous sentiez bien dans votre corps
à bientôt
et nous avons été rejoint par un autre
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
Grégory canalet bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde
sur la scène électro la musique électro
dans les Yvelines je crois que ce
weekend se clôture la 7e édition du
festival électro chic c'est sur le
territoire de Versailles Grand Parc il
sera l'occasion de jouer autour de la
musique électronique beaucoup d'artistes
beaucoup d'événements se déroulent
autour de cette musique électronique
dans le département des Yvelines
le jeudi mais avant on va parler de
disco c'est le retour de la disco roller
ce samedi les chocs d'Élancourt le club
de roller hockey organise leur
traditionnel soirée disco roller au
gymnase chastagnier pour fêter la
Saint-Patrick pour en parler avec nous
Nicolas Thomas bonsoir alors vous êtes
le président des chocs dès l'encours
Nicolas Thomas a quoi faut-il s'attendre
si on n'a jamais participé si on n'est
jamais venu à cette soirée un peu
traditionnelle de discours roller alors
c'est déjà à la base c'est un événement
familial donc on y vient en famille
enfants parents grand-mère qui ont vu
les grands-mères fondu
à plus de 70 ans donc et puis patine
très bien
et puis il sera là donc si vous voulez
le rencontrer il y a pas de problème et
donc c'est un événement où les
participants donc patine en musique dans
la bonne humeur
donc dans le gymnase qui est sécurisé
pour l'occasion à l'aide de balustrade
et on peut on peut assimiler ça à ce
qu'on peut retrouver dans des soirées
patinoires classiques de patins à glace
ou à ce que certains ont peut-être
connus à la main jaune il y a quelques
années voilà alors quels sont les
musiques qu'on pourra entendre c'est du
disco mais est-ce que vous pouvez tout
ce qui est c'est à la fois
des styles années 80 90 évidemment mais
aussi des choses très actuelles toutes
les playlists qu'on peut entendre
sur les radios sans donner le nom de
type pop rock par exemple voilà et donc
une nouvelle fois cette année c'est sur
le thème de la Saint-Patrick est-ce que
on doit absolument venir en vert
non non c'est un code c'est un code
vestimentaire et puis
on aimerait voir le plus sur le plus le
plus grand grand nombre de personnes
mais il y a aucune obligation de ce
côté-là la déco par contre sera sur le
thème de la Saint-Patrick en vert avec
des lutins et tout ce qu'il faut et les
lumières qui vont avec alors d'année en
année la disco roller revient à
Élancourt c'est un rendez-vous vous avez
des fidèles qui attendent ça avec
impatience on a des on a nos fidèles nos
adhérents
mais on a également un certain nombre de
gens de l'extérieur qu'on connaît pas et
qu'on ne voit qu'aux disco roller il y
en a deux dans l'année on en a une au
mois de novembre qui est plutôt à plus
de caritatif et celle du mois de du mois
de mars qui est tout le temps calé sur
la Saint-Patrick et donc on a on a
beaucoup de gens qui nous suivent sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui nous
demandent régulièrement
la date de notre prochaine livreur quand
on l'a pas encore communiqué
tout à fait et on échangeait justement
off vous disiez après le covid 1re
discours roller qui s'est déroulé
l'année dernière après le covid il y
avait une vraie attente des gens pour ce
rendez-vous reviennent justement à
partir du moment où les restrictions le
covid ont commencé à se lever on a eu on
a eu des demandes
assez important bien plus que ce qu'on
imaginait et plusieurs mois en avance de
nous demandons quand aura lieu cette
nouvelle discover donc ça a été un une
vraie motivation pour pour la relancer
et on n'a pas été déçu puisqu'on a eu on
a eu quelque chose comme 1150 entrées là
où habituellement on est plutôt à 110
120 d'entre elles tout à fait est-ce que
ça vous tente autour du plateau la disco
roder je crois que Céline semble que
vous vous faites du roller c'est une
discipline d'ailleurs qui revient de
plus en plus le roller avance
aujourd'hui nos cours donc nous on a
trois activités on a l'activité de
départ qui est une activité de roller
hockey qui est assimilable à dû hockey
sur glace sur sur patin une activité de
course d'enduro où on va au 24 Heures du
Mans roller ce genre de chose et puis on
a une grosse activité ce qu'on a appelé
au départ initiation roller donc on
donne des cours de roller de
l'apprentissage
au départ c'était vraiment dans un but
de de d'apprendre aux gens à patiner
aujourd'hui on a des cours confirmés
avec avec des gens qui ont très très
gros niveau
et on a fait ces créneaux là sur le plan
tous les ans on est sur la partie enfant
on est sur l'île d'attente on ne prend
plus d'inscription environ 15 jours
avant le forum des associations donc les
gens viennent nous voir en forme des
assauts on leur dit bah on est désolé
mais c'est sur sur les attentes et sur
les adultes autour du 10 septembre la
liste est terminée
beaucoup quand j'étais petit est-ce que
c'est comme le vélo ça s'oublie pas le
roller ça revient vite ça revient vite
tout à fait parce que moi aussi j'en
faisais quand j'étais petite mais
j'avoue que là
il y aurait des chutes faut venir le
voir samedi vous avez aucun risque il y
a pas de voiture il y a rien ça tout est
vraiment sécurisé et vous Philippe
nizeau ça vous tenterait
la musique je suis même capable de faire
du rôle
[Musique]
et bien merci Nicolas Thomas d'avoir
accepté notre invitation si vous êtes
intéressez la disco roller c'est ce
samedi 18 mars de 17h30 à 21h30 au
gymnase à chastagnier d'Élancourt le
prix d'entrée s'élève à 3 euros et
attention les rollers ne seront pas
fournis il faudra vous munir de vos
propres rollers allez c'est l'heure
maintenant de passer à nos idées de
sortie dans les Yvelines c'est avec vous
c'est ninja on commence par quoi ce soir
alors on commence par le prox raide
aventure c'est la ville de Rambouillet
qui l'organise samedi 18 mars de 10h à
17h sur l'esplanade Kennedy rue du
muguet à Rambouillet au cours de la
journée vous serez invité à découvrir
plusieurs activités sportives encadrées
par des policiers on retrouve par
exemple de la box du football des cours
de self-defense de l'escalade ou encore
des ateliers de prévention routière les
métiers de la police municipale et
nationale de la gendarmerie nationale et
des sapeurs-pompiers et jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers seront également
représentés par plusieurs stands toutes
les animations sont gratuites et
ouvertes à tous vous nous présentez un
autre événement sportif Céline au
Vésinet cette fois-ci
à peu près trois ans d'absence les
Foulées de la marguerite reviennent ce
dimanche 19 mars pour une sixième
édition trois cours sont proposés au
départ du lac des ibis une course enfant
d'un kilomètre une course plaisir de 3
km et une course sport de 9 km pour les
plus sportifs attention les départs ne
sont pas à la même heure pensez à vous
renseigner à vos inscrire sur le site
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran cette
année la course à pied solidaire sera au
profit de l'association Simon de sirène
qui développe et anime des maisons
partagées ou cohabitent des personnes
valides et handicapées vous allez nous
parler maintenant de de poésie la 25e
édition du Printemps des poètes se
poursuit dans le cadre du Printemps des
Poètes vous avez rendez-vous ce samedi
18 mars au Théâtre Robert Manuel de
plaisir pour un spectacle poétique
autour de Frida Kahlo et des poètes
surréalistes français comme Charles
breton ou encore Aragon 3 artistes vous
livreront en mots et en musique
l'univers intellectuelle et poétique du
pari des années 30 le spectacle est
gratuit mais la réservation est
fortement conseillée on continue en
musique maintenant direction la la
batterie de Guyancourt oui Mathilda
ville maintenant aux fans de musique pop
rock et surtout de découverte musicale
la batterie de Guyancourt vous donne
rendez-vous ce samedi 18 à 20h30 vous le
savez peut-être que ce soit des amateurs
ou des plus expérimentés plus de 200
musiciens fréquentes régulièrement les
studios de répétition de la batterie ce
samedi ce sont trois groupes de studios
qui vont venir se produire pour vous ou
un SD spirits headback ou encore why not
cover et composition sont au programme
l'entrée est gratuite et vous avez la
possibilité de réserver sur le site de
la batterie un tout autre style musical
à présent le festival électro chic se
termine ce week-end il vous reste deux
petits jours pour profiter de ce
rendez-vous phare de la musique électro
vendredi 17 mars DJ Neya vous proposera
un mélange des styles house afro House
et nuit disco au théâtre de Bailly à
20h30 le samedi 18 plusieurs sets sont
prévus au théâtre Londres de vélizy-véla
couplet à 20h vous retrouverez le duo à
toi-même les célèbres les célèbres Brax
et Falcon et enfin Irène Drezel la
soirée je proposera également son
traditionnel tremplin ou 5 candidats
s'affront en musique et seront soumis au
vote d'un jury de professionnels merci
beaucoup c'est ninja alors je vous
propose de continuer tout de suite avec
le quiz Grégory vu que vous allez à nos
challenger sur le festival et les fins
non pas sur le festival électro chic
mais sur la musique électro et oui elle
m'a attendu la perche avec la fin de ce
festival et sur le territoire de
Versailles Grand Parc des adeptes de
musique électro oui bien sûr on va le
prouver tout de suite
à l'ancienne à l'époque de Jean-Michel
Jarre ou autre mais ça donne mais bon ça
reste de la musique électronique alors
ce festival se déroulait sur le
territoire de Versailles grandparc on va
justement débuter sur ce territoire de
Versailles berceau de la musique
électronique française Air Étienne de
Crécy Alex goofer Phoenix tous sont
originaires de la cité royale ces
artistes ont même été à l'origine d'un
courant célèbre un courant musical
célèbre dans les années 1990 2000
première question quel est le nom de ce
courant
des années 2010 pour le coup enfin de
Nîmes de 2010
d'électro pop non c'est un mot anglais
qui m'allait un petit indice français en
anglais
French
a dit French non il y a pas eu le
deuxième mot c'est French Touch la bonne
réponse et oui la french touchez
alors certains ont voulu rebaptiser même
la Versailles touch un thon la cité
royale étant cette ville de Versailles a
donné à la scène électronique française
beaucoup de ces artistes se sont côtoyés
au lycée Jules Ferry à Versailles
Phoenix eux se sont fréquentés du côté
du lycée Hoche à l'époque il y avait
même des concerts qui se tenaient des
concerts improvisés dans les caves
versaillaises le musicien est
réalisateur Marcolin est revenu sur
cette fantastique histoire de la musique
électronique à la sauce versaillesse
dans son documentaire why Versailles qui
est sorti l'an passé petite devinette
nos vrais noms sont Thomas Bangalter et
Guy manuel de au même cristaux nous
avons démocratisé la French Touch dans
le monde entier et contrairement à la
légende urbaine nous ne sommes pas vers
la bonne réponse a été donnée en face
les Daft Punk bien évidemment les Daft
Punk les Français les plus célèbres de
la musique électronique dans le monde
entier one more time heure and the world
Get Lucky on ne compte plus les succès
plus de 10 millions d'albums ont été
vendus en autant tout dans le monde en
28 ans de carrière le groupe s'est
séparé en 2021 et non malgré les rumeurs
persistantes les Daft Punk ne sont pas
Versailles écoutez ce que disait Thomas
bangatter à ce propos dans une interview
à Télérama en 2013 et puisqu'on parle de
Wikipédia si vous pouviez préciser que
nous ne sommes absolument pas de
Versailles Versailles j'ai dû y mettre
les pieds quatre fois dans ma vie alors
ce qui a pu tromper son monde Philippe
c'est une fiche Wikipédia sur le lycéoch
de Versailles qui affirmait par erreur
que les deux musiciens étaient passés
dans les rangs de l'établissement ou
encore les sociétés d'AFM music tracks
qui sont les deux sociétés de musique
des Daft Punk qui ont été domiciliens à
temps 9 rue de Versailles non pas
Versailles mais à Marnes-la-Coquette
dans les Hauts-de-Seine très bonne
réponse en face on va noter le pas envie
de Nicolas Thomas de Thomas borgelter
golem de monter de motif cristaux non de
Guillaume de Guy manuel de au même
cristaux voilà j'avais oublié son nom
troisième question chaque année à la fin
de l'été l'île des Impressionnistes de
Chatou se transforme en un temple de la
musique électro un festival créé par le
DJ et Joachim Garraud ou tous les
courants ils sont représentés grâce à
plusieurs scènes disposées sur place il
y en avait cinq lors de la douzième
édition qui s'est doré les trois et
quatre septembre dernier
je suis assez rapide parce que j'ai pas
envie qu'on me chope les points
la question pour un champion
NES bien sûr le nom de cet événement 12e
édition l'an passé 27000 festivaliers
qui s'était pressé à l'île des
Impressionnistes parmi les têtes
d'affiche Martin Solveig pour cette
dernière édition en 2021 kungs avait
assuré le show à Chatou pour un premier
festival post crise covid 19 la fête
avait été grande kungs et Martin Solveig
qui seront justement à l'affiche de ce
grand événement dédié à la musique
électronique vous pouvez voir les images
s'afficher ce grand événement se tiendra
le 27 mai dans les Yvelines mais dans
quel lieu se déroulera ce rendez-vous
du château de Versailles dans les
jardins du château
aujourd'hui elle est très très forte
elle a même été très précise dans la
réponse les jardins du château de
Versailles même plus précisément les
terrasses du château de Versailles le
nom de cet événement tout simplement
Versailles électro qui revient pour une
troisième édition le 27 mai de 20h à
minuit les deux premières éditions
étaient à guichet fermé et pour cette
année les prix des billets vont de 45 €
jusqu'à même 250 € c'est le tarif gold
voilà pour assurer sa place du côté du
Versailles électro et les places s'en
vont très vite si vous voulez les
prendre autour du plateau le territoire
evinois qui est un territoire privilégié
pour la musique électro électro chic
électrique Park Versailles électro il y
aura aussi la deuxième édition de
l'insula festival cet été sur l'île de
la loge et un petit nouveau ce sera la
dernière question à qui va également
débarquer le trium festival c'est le nom
de ce nouvel événement le teaser ce
rendez-vous actuellement qui s'affiche
aussi à l'écran et il a été tourné
d'ailleurs sur le lieu qui va accueillir
ce rendez-vous où nous situons nous
dernière question
là c'est très dur je crois que c'est
dans un parcs
c'est dans un espace naturel les
Brévières mais c'est pas les bréviaires
on est dans l'agglomération de
50 ans
de ce quiz aujourd'hui l'île de loisirs
de 50 ans d'hiver alors c'était très
très peu reconnaissable il faut le dire
à l'image première édition du triom
festival les 7 et 8 juillet prochain du
côté de l'île de loisirs ce sera très
précisément sur la partie sud-est de
l'île de loisirs au niveau du Relais des
canards d'hier une quarantaine
d'artistes français et internationaux
ils sont attendus pour un rendez-vous
placé bien sûr sur le signe de la
musique électronique de la nature et du
lien social bravo Mathilde vous avez
remporté le quiz ce soir il y avait un
bon point également de l'autre côté un
demi voilà
c'est assez c'est assez insolite qui
remporte le quiz voilà une première
victoire
l'année prochaine bravo en tout cas
merci beaucoup Grégory en tout cas pour
toutes ces informations vous êtes allés
chercher très loin pour nous apporter
toutes ces informations c'était très
intéressant c'est bientôt la fin de
cette émission mais juste avant je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
demain matin le ciel sera nuageux avec
des averses à prévoir du côté de
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan au niveau de
Versailles et Rambouillet ça devrait
rester sec selon Météo France côté
température compter 10 degrés vers ou
dans Versailles et Rambouillet il fera
11 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie dans
l'après-midi le ciel sera toujours bien
chargé à versaillir Rambouillet la pluie
sera toujours présente vers
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan côté
température il fera 15 degrés en moyenne
sur l'ensemble des Yvelines et alors
pour ce week-end quel temps fera-t-il
Céline c'est avec un ciel voilé que vous
allez débuter ce week-end la matinée du
samedi sera fraîche avec 11 degrés sur
la totalité du département l'après-midi
le temps sera à l'orage avec des averses
les températures elles monteront
légèrement il fera 12 degrés à
Rambouillet très à Mantes-la-Jolie ou
dans eversize le soleil fera son retour
le dimanche matin des éclaircisses sont
attendus dans tout le département du
côté des températures il fera 10 degrés
à Rambouillet et Houdan 11 à Monte la
jolie et Versailles pas de changement ce
qui concerne le temps l'après-midi il
fera 13 degrés à Rambouillet 12 à Houdan
et Versailles et 11 à Rambouillet merci
beaucoup Céline la jolie
le temps sera assez clément ce weekend
merci beaucoup Céline c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
jusqu'au bout avec nous je vous souhaite
une belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin
de vous
[Musique]